we have this from timcast.com Liberty
Safe cites company protocol on decision
to provide FBI with access code let me
slow down this is about the January 6
cases for those that aren't familiar a
guy was arrested
he had a Liberty Safe a gun safe
Liberty was contacted by the FBI who
said we have a warrant for his premises
so they gave the code to the safe to the
FBI now there's a lot of questions that
arise from this
how did they have the code to the safe
in the first place
easy it appears that Liberty has
publicly admitted as a safe company they
have a back door to all of your safes
this means if you own a liberty safe for
your guns you are compromised
period This is not political this is not
I don't like the company because they
betrayed a guy or whatever look I'll
tell you this right now
if a company receives a court order to
hand over information I fully expect you
to do it we are a nation of due process
and laws and if a judge signs off on a
legitimate warrant or court order saying
you're going to turn this information
over we expected it to happen when we
subpoena the doj or whatever when the
Republicans do when the in Congress and
they don't do it we get mad about it if
a court order is given down we respect
it now there's a bunch of questions here
Liberty apparently didn't get a court
order they were shown a warrant for
someone else's house and then said sure
we'll give you we'll give you the code
anyway that's got a lot of people pissed
off but more importantly outside of all
the politics if you purchased a Liberty
Safe understand that at any point for
any reason legal or illegal someone else
has access to your safe and could steal
everything you own and I'll give you a
simple scenario
Liberty has a back door baked into your
safe that means someone has access to
that code I assume it's likely based on
an algorithm pertaining the serial
number of your safe this is typically
how companies generate unique passcodes
and back doors I don't know that this is
exactly how they do it but we do know
they have the code which means
a rogue employee could see an order
comes in for a high-end say for
thousands of dollars which can hold 50
Grand in guns and other equipment or who
knows what gold and then tells one of
their buddies hey here's the address
here's the save model and here's the
backdoor code they wait six months
monitor your home because they know your
address because the guy's got it
now I'm not saying Liberty employees are
compromised I'm just saying why would
you risk it more importantly anyone
could steal the information from Liberty
and now they can break into your safe
this is this is a great the craziest
thing to come out uh in terms of uh you
know the one of the craziest stories so
far Liberty Safe issued a statement
saying that uh it's their policy to give
access codes to law enforcement if it
warrant grants them access to a property
what that means is
a court order was not issued to the gun
safe manufacturer they just showed them
that they have a a warrant for the
property Liberty Safe could have said
when a judge instructor instructs us to
hand over the information we'll do it
but we can't until then and even if they
do they can say our lawyer will appeal
this is absolutely insane to find out
this is resulting in a major backlash I
don't know how big Liberty is but I just
want to stress to you guys if you own a
Liberty Safe you are compromised does
the same thing hold true for home alarm
systems
it look typically
when it comes to uh the answer is yes
when it comes to security we don't
expect them to install backdoor access
to our our our systems that we we buy
right so so let me show you this I have
another I have another tweet people are
already pointing out this is secure it
gun storage they responded saying we
firmly believe in our customers right in
Freedom to control their personal
property recently secure it was made
aware made aware of and asked to comment
on the situation involving the FBI in a
well-known safe manufacturer the FBI
requested the access code to the safe of
an individual for whom they have a
warrant to search their property the
company protocol is to provide these
access codes to law enforcement if a
warrant grants act that grants them
access to the property it is secure its
belief in protocol that the protection
of personal property in the second
amendment rights of American citizens
are Paramount our full line of Fast
Access modular safes are not built with
any override systems giving our
customers full control the freedom and
liberty to possess Firearms is the right
of every American citizen secure it will
always put those same rights of our
current and future customers first that
is to say based on the information
before us if you have a Liberty Safe you
don't know who has the backdoor code
that means
more than just you can go into your safe
maybe you've got your dad's watch your
grandmother's necklace or maybe you've
got a twenty thousand dollar brand new
beautiful Barrett of some sort so with
with tons of ammo and it's yours and
it's expensive and you don't want it
stolen why would you go with a safe
company that runs a back door the
interesting thing is I'm not seeing in
the leftist media direct attacks and
insults like you normally expect from a
story like this why the left has
consistently complained about companies
creating backdoor access to encryption
so it's going to be very difficult for
them to come out and be like haha gun
nuts are losing their uh-oh yeah we
actually don't like that idea either
especially many of these leftists who
are pro-gun so if you have a secure it
safe and the and the FEDS or anyone goes
to them they're going to say look we
don't have access that is a private safe
owned by somebody you got to figure it
out for yourself man I have no idea
Liberty's like don't worry we installed
backdoor access to all of our safes and
we'll give it to you if you ask right I
mean they can they could have some mad
employee to sell the backdoor access to
someone you you never know the fact that
they even got that is is ridiculous
Apple didn't turn over information back
in 2013 right
um I I imagine all of them would now
this this is really really crazy too if
you look at you know uh I think I think
Apple did turn up with some information
well there was a big story where the
feds demanded Apple open a phone and
they were like no way yeah yeah because
here's the thing that's what I'm saying
leftists are very very angry about
backdoor access because you know they do
creepy stuff they have activist servers
they don't want the FED seizing they
don't want so Apple's probably thinking
like if word gets out that we give the
feds access to your device we're gonna
lose a lot of money in market share so
just don't do it unless you absolutely
have to
good luck Liberty Safe I guess this is a
big part of the reason why uh as a
social network and just in general you
don't want to hold more data than you
need because then you become a
vulnerability like mines uh doesn't have
uh
you know chat Keys we don't have access
to the chat at Minds because uh it's
encrypted and it's user to user like if
you have the keys then when the FBI
comes that you have to give them to the
FBI legally you're off you're expected
to do it uh it's better not to hold the
data I would say immediately get rid of
your Liberty Safe if you've got one to
get a new safe that doesn't have a back
door in it because that is massive
vulnerability so someone could steal
your gun out of there and and use it to
commit a crime and make dude make it
look like you did it there's so much
there's so much wrong with this uh I
would argue that they are not secure at
all if a back door is installed someone
could figure out all right so I don't I
don't know exactly how they generate
backdoor passcodes it could be the
stupidest thing in the world where
Liberty Safe has a master code for all
saves is identical which would be insane
for all I know they're then one two
three four I mean yo they they used to
do this uh without me naming the system
itself there were very common machines
that were available to the public
everywhere and their their unlock code
was based it was like 54321 and they
just figured nobody would know how to
access the panel to do it and then on
the internet they were like hey guys
here's how you can access the the the
the control systems for these widely
available machines I'll keep it simple
they were vending machines but I'm not
gonna say which ones and people started
changing prices and doing crazy crazy
stuff and it was like they didn't expect
it to happen and then after people
caught on they said guys change the
default code on these machines but
as Ian was pointing out imagine somebody
uh let's imagine two scenarios One
Liberty uses a default master code it's
16 digits and it can open any safe okay
you're compromised beyond belief anyone
can just go in and do this
now imagine they don't do that but
what a lot of companies do let's say
routers
the router will have a serial number
they have an algorithm which creates an
a passcode based on the serial number of
the of the router if you don't know the
algorithm you don't get the password
however activists in Spain
took a whole bunch of passwords they
knew and a whole bunch of serial numbers
and then ran it basically through an
algorithm to determine what the
encryption was and from that point on
when I was in Spain they they had an app
for this that they made we're sharing
you could if the if the default name of
the device was still available and it
would say like you know mobile router
78391 a62 it would instantly generate
the passcode based on the default name
of the router
the same thing could be true for Liberty
Safes someone could break into the house
with an app take a p type in the serial
number and then it auto generates the
backdoor access key these things are
worthless hunks of garbage I think there
should be a massive lawsuit I think
there should be a class action suit I
think anybody who has one of these
things should get a refund on it I I
don't know I don't it's crazy to hear
this and they're saying it's their
policy if you bought this and they
didn't disclose that there's actually
backdoor access you got they they robbed
you yeah oh I imagine now do they have
do every company like this have to uh uh
like do they have to inform you that
they have backdoor access I don't think
so I mean you buyer beware if you if you
you know right like if you sell the
product there are some things you have
to disclose and some things you don't
you know in California if you're selling
food you gotta say it's got carcinogens
in it but some things you don't have to
well maybe this should be something that
people have to do that these companies
have to do you'll need a federal law for
that good luck getting that passed yeah
that's that's tough the federal
government is Lodge it's a good point
yeah
if they didn't know they were getting
sold a machine with a back door uh
that's that's scandalous yeah and I
think the FBI already knew before they
even called uh whatever what is this
what is it called Liberty Safe yeah
Liberty Safe they already knew
the FBI already knew where they wouldn't
have called them exactly they knew
consider
the fact that the FBI contacted them and
said can you give us the back door key
that's crazy man
did they make you guys know Liberty I
don't know we'll Google it how
ubiquitous is this company right now gun
sales and maybe this is something that
that Trump should I know you said it's
going to be hard you know getting
something like uh uh getting something
passed to where these companies have to
inform the buyers that they have you
know backdoor access
but why not let them know like
why not why should they wait why why
would the I mean why shouldn't they know
when you move into a house you change
your locks yeah you're moving to a new
apartment you change your locks would
you buy a deadbolt for your house if the
package said and a random guy you don't
know also has a copy of your key hell no
you'd be like what I don't know out of
here dude hell no but but at the end of
the day I want to know I want to know
and I think I should know that yeah
because because it's my safety you could
have some mad crazy insane employee who
could you know get access to my house I
I should know this there's like you can
go to a Home Depot and get a copy of
your key Med but who's to say that they
didn't just make an extra copy for
themselves right that's true
what a it's not a yeah that that is very
true not that they know what your key is
for necessarily but well they have a
copy
because they made you a copy so so so
they have the digital print for it you
know but they might not know what it's
for he's saying right like what what's
the key for even yeah hopefully not
I mean I imagine like if you're buying
something like this it has some type of
um manual on how to use it and it's
probably buried in the fine print in the
back of the manual
that the that the access would be given
up if need be yeah if you forget your
code you can always use zero zeros you
know whatever the hell is some people
say you know I've been some people say
and after this came out a lot of people
are saying we just don't have privacy at
all really like there's no such thing as
real privacy in this country dude
there's there's satellites that can like
track your the noise you're making I
don't know the technology exactly but
they said that there's like they can put
like a I don't know if it's a radio
frequency or something through your
walls in your house and then listen
through listen to you through your
through your walls like what the I kind
of tend to agree that privacy's gone
like I think we can go out in the woods
and have a really quiet conference like
this but who's to say that the the
satellites aren't picking it up at this
point I don't know I don't feel like
anything's private these days I got
Alexa on in the freaking listening my
phone if you say OK Google it Sparks
this stupid thing don't say it you just
did and it's like how innocuous is that
that three words can trigger
millions of devices to go off and then
it's like your your phone says like if
you uh if you would like us to not have
access hit this button like I'm sure
you're absolutely listening to this I'm
sure you're I'm sure you followed the
letter of the law which should be off by
default my God that should be off by
default someone super chatted saying
that it was a Public Square company
let's pull it up
uh wasn't there a story about like
Zuckerberg's phone got hacked once and
his password was like d-a-d-a well I saw
a commercial with Sean Hannity promoting
uh the safe coming yeah the Safe Company
really yeah there's one versus a big
deal yeah
I mean they're gonna have to just remove
it yeah they can't Let's uh let's search
it
Liberty
TNT Liberty Safe sounds at the same
company is it different company
people register their safer yeah no this
is a different company
this is very much a different company
guys
this is TNT
so that's good to find out unless I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure it's a
different company
this uh the other the other company is
uh
let me see I'm I'm searching for it
the Liberty States we're talking about
is based out of Utah this one said TNT
so let's not say where TNT yeah it's
different okay I'm pretty sure it's a
different company so there's more than
one Liberty Safe Company
yeah this one's just Liberty and then
it's a safe really small underneath it
yeah yeah the you're thinking something
different we do not besmirch the good
name of of a separate company that did
nothing wrong uh look I got if if
Liberty saves comes out and says we're
abandoning this policy we are revoking
all back door access it will be none of
our models we can we'll have this
anymore I'd be like okay awesome that's
fantastic thank you and that's it and
then buy their saves but in the meantime
ah dude I'd say uh if you have a Liberty
Safe dude holy crap I believe the
government has access to everything
everyone else does like you can't trust
a government agent not to tell your
buddy down the street you can't your
past your safe password so the next time
he's over having dinner
you can just go into your bedroom and
like what well of course you gotta
obviously that's like a string of crazy
events but it's possible but look look
you you you've got spare keys to your
apartment or your house and a neighbor
has them in case of emergencies but it's
because you trust your neighbor like
like I said imagine if you went to the
hardware store and it said quadruple
ultimate level 27 Ultra lock and the key
is like this weird long snake thing with
all these spikes on it you can't even
understand you're like wow and it's like
plus with every order a key is given to
a random guy you've never met you'd be
like
what bill and security has a copy in
case you in case you lose yours and
he'll come over and you can totally our
our company has a has a secret key to
all the locks we sell and we you know
and we're going to give it to whoever we
feel like deserves it without a court
order so a locksmith can a locksmith
came to my house he changed out all the
locks in my home and he was like man I
just gotta tell you I love you I'm a big
fan and
I appreciated that that he was a fan but
I was uncomfortable because you don't
say anything that means God knows me
like he's gonna go he's like can't wait
to tell my wife and
cousin
oh no
he's probably a good guy but he's going
to go home he's going to tell everybody
where I live so I called another
locksmith out to him and said I need all
my locks changed again the thing about
your typical pin and Tumble locks the
ones you have like what is it I think
it's five numbers so uh I'm not an
expert on this but my general
understanding is that there's the
grooves correlate with numbers and if
you know the numbers you can cut the key
so it so a locksmith for instance when
you when you call locksmith and then he
you know sticks the key in and then he
marks it and does it again and then he
creates a key to open the door he knows
the numbers of your key and can recreate
it pretty easily not to mention I just
got to be honest you guys the lock on
your door
if you really think that's keeping
anybody around like obviously for one
someone could kick a door in very easily
very true but there's things called bump
Keys which are basically filed down to
the lowest point and you just tap it in
and turn it it pops right open there's
also uh rakes and locksmiths tend to use
like a I think it's called a rate gun
it's just a it's a device you stick in
and you and you pull it you pull it and
it Jiggles the pins until it pops open
really easy to get access to that's why
you need a gun
you gotta defend yourself that's why you
need it done thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time